bonsoir chantal corcos merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france vous êtes
donc à rio tout d'abord comment vous
décririez la situation sanitaire sur
place écoutez la situation s'est vite et
ici n'est pas jésus des plus
catastrophiques elle était en fait on a
nous avons une augmentation des cas mais
curieusement pas une augmentation de la
mortalité
c'est peut-être dû au fait que nous
avons une vaccination des personnes
âgées
jusqu'à peu près 59 ans ça représente
10% de la population c'est très très bas
l'action est très lente mais ont atteint
ou au moins de mars les quatre mille et
trois mille morts par jour là on est à
une moyenne de 14 jours à 1500 1600 donc
dire que l'on y compris est possible
qu'on reparte
non il est possible qu'on reparte mais
je veux dire actuellement on a en a une
occupation des lits de soins intensifs à
peu près entre 70% et 90%
sachant bien sûr que le brésil est grand
comme cinq fois la france dont vous avez
des disparités et dans l'antre des
régions où il ya plus de 80% de
contaminer en plus et d'autres regardent
moins 5% à 30% tout dépend donc les
jours vous vous cassez en tout cas
certains épidémiologistes alerte à une
troisième vague encore plus meurtrière
j'avoue qu'on a du mal à s'imaginer
comment ça peut être encore plus
meurtrier encore plus grave au brésil
vous vous y croyez à c'est à ces
prédictions en tout cas ces alertes
extrêmement pessimiste écoutez moi je
suis médecin donc je suis je jure je
fréquente les une péniche privé un jeu
j'ai des collègues qui fréquentent aussi
et les les hôpitaux publics
alors qu'on voit une certaine
augmentation des as
hospitalisé j'ai des patients à risques
utilisés moins grave parce qu'ils ont à
peu près 50 ans 40 ans jose pitt alizés
un jeune homme de 27 ans qui restait 48
heures qui était limite donc voilà c'est
mon expérience non je n'ai pas deux
aujourd'hui oui aussi donnez moi de vous
couper
souvent on a critiqué la gestion de la
crise au brésil les mesures sanitaires
qui n'était pas forcément mise en place
il ya aussi la vaccination tout à la
fois aujourd'hui ou vraiment le problème
aujourd'hui c'est seulement 10% +2 18%
même la population qui est immunisée
c'est pas assez
certainement parce qu'il ya eu il ya eu
des achats vaccins qui n'ont pas été
faits en fin 2020 vous signale qu'il ya
une commission denquête ils entendent
lui qui aujourd'hui c'est les
investigations sur quels sont les freins
et se tenant les aboutissants de cette
affaire dont il ya tout une crise
politique autour de l'achat tout de la
famille de la gestion de la stratégie
vaccinale du brésil
voilà alors que nourrit on a eu un
réseau aussi intéressant c'est unique au
corps et la vaccination nous n'a pas
aidé les vaccins achetées au bon moment
vie donc on manque de maxime a réagi la
population devant cette gestion de
l'épidémie qui décidément plus d'un an
avant après le début de l'épidémie qui
est toujours aussi poussive aussi
laborieuse
oui écoutez mal parce que tout de même
nous avons l'exemple de pays qui à
partir du moment où ils sont vaccinés ou
dans des conditions économiques
meilleures 1 et ici nous sommes dans un
pays en voie de développement donc les
conditions économiques sont très
importantes aussi importante
que dans le monde entier et beaucoup de
personnes dépendent de leur travail
quotidien pour mettre à manger est sur
la table tous les jours il ya des gens
qui travaillent aux autres je croyais à
non pas des salaires qui gagne journée
et qui sont obligés de sortir j'ai le
tram défense mango se subsister et
pourtant c'est dans ce contexte que la
copa america de football du brésil doit
doit démarrer dimanche on a du mal à
l'imaginer
ici c'est son cloche voilà de longs mois
c'est une décision éminemment politique
c'est encore un scandale politique
le ou deux dit si bien il en fait il ya
une pollari et brésil des pour et des
contres est bon même si les joueurs vont
être testés tous les clés toutes les 48
heures il n'est pas dit qu'elle nous
amène pas variante à ce moment-ci signer
à rien alors yang remake c'est
contagieux imaginer qu'ils amènent le
variant indien afin de dire cessantes
femme est en fait on a comme on parle
enfin les aucune stratégie par rapport à
la protection des frontières au cul en
tout cas quand alain korkos un médecin
généraliste au consulat français de rio
de janeiro merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france